[MUSIC]
Tsukasa-kun
, you can't match me now You
should have known from the beginning that
yes's hole is literally a fatal injury
[MUSIC]
Then why are you struggling?
[Music]
I don't know, but I'll
do it soon [Music] Even if I do, I still want to buy the 707 Maybe it was fun Say this, it's a short-lived joint struggle Is that so sad?
It's over
[Music]
[Applause]
Leader
, bandages on your fingertips will surely drop the measuring instrument
Cutting is the name of the company.
Ignition o
Atomic science isn't bad either
Team 0
Batteries are the first time
you've spent a month in a row wow!
It's a job,
movie light You kindly delivered the materials, didn't you?
Which tag is there?